hey everyone and welcome to another hd
hopefully uh video this one's going to
be a review and one of my first hardware
review videos this one is going to be a
review of the case that i unbox for the
lg voyager so this is the uh the hard
rubberized case that i showed you guys
and um i'm just going to go over
installation real quick and by the way i
will not uh actually i will be using
noise cancellation for this video and
i'm using my new microphone here so um
here we go this is the uh front of the
phone itself and the front case again
this is made of
if i can just show you
it's a really soft uh kind of a rubber
feel but it's also a hard rubber case so
it's kind of interesting
to put it on we just put it on the phone
push down and wait till you hear a snap
i'm actually installing it during this
video because uninstallation is a real
pain
i have to show you guys more about that
but i put it on the back of the phone
it's the same thing it kind of fits
right over uh there's little uh hinges
where you can put it on the phone and it
hinges on to the uh the outside parts of
the phone so when you hear the clicks
that is how you know that it is done uh
that you're done with the installation
so now that we're done installing i can
go over the basically
the main features of this case i'm going
to try to move uh move the microphone
and try sorry about that try to move the
microphone over here so um what i want
to show you is that the front of the
case is basically you get all this room
for the buttons you get all this um open
space so you can press the send end and
clear keys that's pretty cool you do get
a little uh opening there for the uh
speaker so when you're talking on the
phone there's no obstruction there uh
the thing on the on this side is that
you do have an open slot for the micro
sd card that focuses
and the uh 2.5 millimeter headphone jack
so that's very good on the other side is
completely open okay so there's no
hinges coming down on this side and
there's also it's left wide open on the
uh the front part so you don't have
anything obstructing the hard keys on on
the top
a few things i noticed about this case
on this side there are four you can see
those four holes i actually went on
their website and i was just surfing it
today and i never found out what those
four holes are for it could be for
ventilation it could be for
um for a
belt holster but i never found out um if
there is no build holster in the box so
that's just something to consider and
you know you kind of feel it when you're
texting on the back because i hold my
phone in a certain way that i do have my
thumbs or my fingers there so yeah
that's an interesting feature um so yeah
this case is really really it doesn't
take up that much room if you are
looking for a case that doesn't add that
much bulk to the phone this is not a
very thick phone as you can see
it does have a flip open but it's not a
very thick phone in this case does not
add that much bulk to the phone
what else can i tell you there's not
really that many features about it
because it's not a belt holster but yeah
it does cover the verizon wireless and
the lg branding that you would normally
see so when you were say surfing a web
uh you wouldn't have
there wouldn't be anything in the way um
even though if you're trying to touch
something on the outside edge of the
screen that might be obstructed a little
bit but otherwise that's it i mean it's
pretty good that you don't have anything
kind of distracting
so if you're browsing the web in the
dark there's nothing reflective or
anything so that's pretty cool um what
else can i tell you this is really a
well well designed case okay you can uh
you can get one at the link in the
description it's a very very uh very
good price so if you do uh visit that
link you can get this for i think ten
dollars it is so um
yeah i want to thank extreme pda for
sending this out to me it's a really
really nice case and i think this is now
going to be my default case because
before i was using a soft one this is
actually a better case and it does um
it does work with my headphones so if i
do plug in the headphones there they
don't fall out um one last thing is that
uh in another case that i was using when
i wanted to charge the phone you kind of
have to
bring back that charging flap there if i
could uh take it back but i can't really
do it at the moment because this this
little thing right here that latches on
to the edge of the phone is in the way
so if you do want to charge it you're
going to have to take off the back part
of the case and that is kind of
difficult to take off so that is the
only con it's not a lint grabber or
anything it's just an all-around good
case so this has been another hd video
from mkbhd if you'd like to follow me on
twitter uh that link is in us on my
channel and uh you'll get all the
updates and everything i try to update
it a couple times a day and that's
basically it so thanks for watching this
video and make sure you subscribe peace